-President Biden signed his
$1.9 trillion COVID relief
bill into law today,
exactly one year after the
World Health Organization
declared the coronavirus
a pandemic
and the country started
to shut down
and Republicans tried
to both lie about the bill
and claim credit
for the bill at the same time.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Everyone's been reflecting
on the fact
that it's been
exactly one year
since the start of the pandemic
and the shutdowns
and, while most normal
human beings
have looked back solemnly
at the staggering death toll
and all the suffering,
the pain, and misery caused
by the economic crash,
"Fox & Friends" is wondering,
"What if we just like
didn't do anything?"
You wonder where we
would've been a year ago,
had they said, "Okay,
these are the things
to protect yourselves,"
but they had not closed down
the whole planet
and then just given
people the choice.
Where would we be
one year later?
Because today marks the one-year
anniversary of the pandemic.
-I know. Can you imagine where
our economy would be today,
where our healthcare sector
would be today?
Human beings are capable
of good decisions,
if you provide them
with the right information.
It's a thought experiment,
unfortunately, Steve,
we don't get to do in reverse.
-I don't know, guys.
Seems like
the thought experiment
falls apart
when you talk
about providing people
with the right information,
since you work for a network
that might as well be called...
Let's not forget
last year's hits, like,
"It's basically the flu,"
"Masks don't work,"
or the doctor who said
hydroxychloroquine is the answer
is the same doctor
who also believes
demons have sex with men
to collect their sperm.
Do you know how hard
comedy writing is
when the real thing
is demon sperm?
You can't heighten it.
Here, I'll prove it.
Trump's touting a doctor
who believes in demon sperm.
What's next, demon sperm?
See?
There's nowhere else to go.
Sure, I guess
I could say unicorn [bleep],
but they're just going to beep
[bleep]
I can't believe the question
these guys are asking,
after a year
and half a million deaths, is,
"What if, instead
of helping people,
we just like did nothing?"
You sociopaths.
Do you guys not understand
like the germ theory
of disease?
[ Dully ]
Microorganisms spread
from one person to another,
so, in order
to stop the disease,
you have to keep people apart.
I can't believe I have
to explain this to you
like I'm some
19th-century biologist.
"You don't understand.
Diseases are caused
by microbes."
Okay, Louis Pasteur.
Come on, guys.
Let's go drink from the fountain
outside the asylum.
I can't believe it's been a year
since everything shut down.
And, by that,
I mean it's only been a year.
I feel like,
these last 12 months,
we've all aged
at president speed.
Remember how Obama went in
looking like a cast member
on "My So-Called Life"
and came out looking like
he'd just seen
Mitch McConnell's ghost?
That's all of us now.
In fact, I feel like
Obama's the only one
who's somehow gotten younger
in the last year.
He's hanging out
on the vineyard,
doing podcasts,
like a 20-year- old stand-up.
[ As Obama ]
Bruce, I, uh...
got a sweet new audio setup.
Just bought a Yeti
and a pop filter.
But it's true,
it's been exactly one year
since that surreal cascade
of events led
to the shutdown of the country,
from the NBA shutting down
to Tom Hanks getting COVID
and then, of course,
as we all solemnly remember,
the late night shows.
One year ago,
I was here in my studio alone,
after sending our staff home
and canceling our show,
doing "A Closer Look"
for YouTube.
And now, a year later,
I'm here in my studio alone,
doing "A Closer Look" for Wally.
I hope you enjoy them, Wally.
-I mean, I wish they could be
a little shorter.
-Not now, Wally.
-It's really heavy to hold!
-Not now!
I remember that day
like it was yesterday.
Everything was shutting down,
people were scared,
grocery stores were ransacked,
so I got up on a chair
in the office
and gave an inspirational speech
where I said to my staff, "Gang,
I know you're terrified,
but this is our moment.
People are counting on us.
So let's get out there
and put on the best
goddamn show of our lives."
And then I looked down
and the room was empty,
except for a tumbleweed
that rolled past,
stole a bottle of Purell
off my desk, and then left.
[ Wind blowing ]
And it was even worse than that
because I was standing
on top of my chair
and the crew guy
who helps me down from chairs
had left.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know how to do it.
I used to.
Anyway, the point is
it's worth stepping back,
reflecting on everything
the country's been through
over the last year --
all the pain, the suffering,
the joblessness,
rising poverty, food scarcity,
so much of it needless,
thanks, in large part,
to the sociopathic incompetence
of an administration
and political party
that simply did not care
that a deadly virus was
rampaging through the country
and often
did everything it could
to help spread the disease.
It's also been one year
since we all trapped ourselves
inside our homes
with stockpiles of gin
and red wine,
watching "Tiger King"
and "Love Is Blind"
while clinging to our last
shreds of toilet paper,
like a plank floating
in the water after a shipwreck.
Remember that?
When there was a deadly,
mysterious virus
rampaging through the country
and, instead of face masks,
everyone thought the one thing
they'd need was toilet paper?
I have so much residual anxiety
from that
that, when I see a guy
walking down the street
with a 12-pack of Charmin
from the grocery store,
I still can't help
but think to myself,
"[Bleep] you!
[ Laughter ]
You better have 12 [bleep],
buddy."
[ Laughter ]
Also, remember "Love Is Blind"?
I know it was a year ago,
but we still
have to talk about Jessica.
Mostly, in regards to how she
was showing us our own futures.
Everyone thought it was insane
when she gave wine to her dog,
but then quarantine happened
and we all ended up doing
much, much weirder things
to pass the time.
I, for example, developed
a close personal relationship
with a sea captain painting,
so, Jessica,
I am very sorry for judging you.
It's also been exactly one year
since our last president
delivered a bizarre
prime time address
where he struggled to read
off the teleprompter,
got a bunch
of his own policies wrong,
and then did this after he
thought the feed had cut out.
-We will heal the sick,
care for those in need,
help our fellow citizens,
and emerge from this challenge
stronger and more unified
than ever before.
God bless you
and God bless America.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
-We're clear.
-Okay.
Okay. [ Sigh ]
[ Laughter ]
Remember that?
When the president reacted
to his own speech
on a national crisis
like you just told him
you were getting back together
with your ex.
[ As Trump ]
She stole your car to go
have sex with your brother, but,
ah, okay!
[ Laughter ]
Although, my favorite part
of that speech was actually
the bit C-SPAN cut
before it started,
when Trump accidentally
got a pen mark on his suit
and freaked out.
-You have [indistinct].
-A what?
Oh, [bleep]
Uh-oh.
I got a pen mark.
Anybody have any white?
Do you have any white stuff?
-That is definitely not
what you want to see
during a national emergency --
tune in to C-SPAN early
and see the president saying --
[ As Trump ]
Uh-oh. [Bleep]
Oh no!
"What is it, Mr. President,
more bad news on the virus?"
No, way worse, guys.
I got a big old ketchup stain
on my shirt.
You shouldn't have let me
have the Sloppy Joe
right before we went on.
Does anyone have
a Tide to Go stick?
Tide to Go stick? Mel?!
[ Laughter ]
Mel?!
Do you have
the Tide to Go stick?
What?
[ Laughter ]
Say it louder, Mel.
I should Tide to [bleep]?
Mel!
[ Laughter ]
Bring down the white stuff!
No, not cocaine!
Mayonnaise!
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's such a relief
to have a competent
administration
that actually cares
about governing
and a party that just passed
a massive stimulus bill
that will deliver urgent relief
to millions of people,
as opposed to, you know,
a racist, authoritarian,
criminal sociopath
who tried
to overthrow democracy.
But I will still
occasionally reminisce
about how deeply weird he was.
If Trump wants to run again,
we should just create
a second position,
separate from president,
and call it White House Weirdo
or something.
Let him hug all the flags
he wants
and shake Macron's hand
for an hour,
while Biden does all
the actual governing.
And let's not forget, a lot
has changed in the last year
for Trump, too, and not just
because of the pandemic.
Now that he's lost the legal
protections of the presidency,
he's under increasing
criminal scrutiny.
The Wall Street Journal
obtained the audio
of yet another phone call
in which Trump pressured
a Georgia election officials
to throw out valid ballots,
which comes
as the Fulton County D.A.
investigates Trump's bid
to steal the state's votes
and his former fixer
Michael Cohen,
who already went to jail
for a hush money scheme
directed by Trump,
is apparently cooperating
with the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office
in its investigation of Trump's
business dealings and taxes.
-CNN has learned
that Michael Cohen,
former Trump lawyer and fixer,
met with prosecutors from the
Manhattan
District Attorney's Office
for a seventh time,
as their investigation
of the former president
continues.
-Seven interviews.
My God, they're going to have
to publish the indictment
as a multipart series,
like "Game of Thrones."
I'm no lawyer,
but, generally speaking,
it's not good when the
prosecutor investigating you
does more interviews
with your personal fixer
than there are episodes
in an HBO miniseries.
When Trump heard about the
seven interviews with Cohen,
he was probably as shocked
as Nicole Kidman was
when she found out
her charming British husband
with a mysterious past,
who's estranged from his family,
and conspicuously left his phone
at home during a trip
that he was purposely
vague about
might have killed someone.
When Trump got the call
about Cohen's seven interviews,
he probably was like --
-Oh, [bleep]
-But Trump's bizarre
halfhearted speech one year ago
is a stunning contrast with the
seriousness and gravitas
of the speech President Biden
delivered tonight,
exactly one year later,
to mark the pain
the country's endured,
while also offering hope
for the future.
Vaccinations are ramping up,
cases are headed down,
and, today, Biden signed a bill
that will inject
$1.9 trillion into the economy
to help struggling Americans
who need and deserve it.
The bill's enormously popular.
75% of Americans
and 59% of Republicans
approve of that.
Do you know how hard it is
to get 75% approval
for anything?
I can't even get 75% approval
from my crew
for my impression
of Michael Shannon
playing various
Looney Tune characters.
[ As Shannon/Bugs Bunny ]
Get ready to die, [bleep],
because it's duck season
in this part of town.
You should've made a left turn
at Albuquerque, mother[bleep].
[ As Shannon/Foghorn Leghorn ]
I say!
[ Laughter ]
I say, I say, boy!
What is the big idea?
[ Laughter ]
Are you threatening me, boy?
I am the cock of the walk
around here.
Nobody threatens
Foghorn
Alfredo
Leghorn.
[ Laughter ]
We brought it back
one more time.
I promise that's it.
For today.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway.
Point is, the bill
is massively popular
with voters in both parties
and, yet,
Republicans have derided it
as a so-called partisan bill
and gone so far as to pretend
that it doesn't even
do that much about COVID,
which is a total lie.
-I'm extremely disappointed
in Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer.
This is a very partisan bill.
-There was no reason for them
to jam through
this $1.9 trillion bill.
-I think we might have
a new name
for this package
that's come over.
It's the Porky Partisan, uh,
Pricy...Pet Project...Package.
-It's just unbelievable.
This thing is just
so corrupt, so costly,
and you look at it,
it's just so liberal.
-$1.9 trillion of relief
that mostly has nothing
to do with COVID.
-President Biden says it's
a coronavirus bill
and my response is,
"Right, you know,
and the stripper
really likes you."
-What?
What are you talking about?
It says a lot about Kennedy
that he thinks that's an analogy
that makes the most sense
to people.
[ As Kennedy ]
We've all been there, Brian.
You're at the club
and you strike up a conversation
with one of the dancers --
Misty's my favorite --
and you make it feel
like you're having
a real connection.
Next thing you know,
you go in for a hug
and the bouncer's throwing you
out on the sidewalk,
telling you you're banned
from The Diamond Donkey,
which is bad news because they
got the best shrimp in town.
And that's
what this COVID bill is.
It just the strip club shrimp.
You can't have it anymore.
It's all COVID money.
The $1,400 checks,
that's COVID money.
The money to reopen schools,
fund state and local governments
to pay pensions,
to keep services running
and people employed,
that's COVID money, too.
Bot to mention the money
for vaccinations
and public health.
But Kennedy continued
with his deranged analogy.
-It's just chock full
of spending porn.
And, if you add up all
the coronavirus spending
and then, all the spending porn,
there's no comparison
and, to me,
using a coronavirus bill
to effectuate spending porn
is like looting
after a natural disaster.
-Jesus, dude,
I don't love "Fox & Friends,"
but it's a morning show.
You can't come out
firing "strippers"
and "porn" everywhere.
I mean, save something
for Hannity.
What's left for him?
[ As Kennedy ] I want to talk
about unicorn [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
You're a weird man.
I can't follow a word
you're saying.
Are you trying to sound
like Boomhauer?
Because that interview
would actually make more sense.
-Are you celebrating the
greatest progressive bill
in the history of our country?
-We go --
[ Continues indistinctly ]
man, a little --
with a little squirt gun.
-But I have to say, some of the
most galling behavior came
from Republicans
who actually tried
to take credit
for elements of the bill,
while also voting against it.
-Republican Senator Roger Wicker
of Mississippi tweeted today,
after the bill passed the House,
he tweeted...
Sounds like he's all for it
-Sure does.
-and was part of passing it.
He actually voted
against the bill,
as did every single Republican
in the Congress.
-You voted against it.
If you'd gotten your way,
restaurants wouldn't have gotten
a dime of that money.
You can't just turn around
and claim credit for it.
I know these guys are shameless,
but I'm still shocked.
They're the kind of guys
who would run out
and try to lift Tom Brady
on their shoulders
while wearing Chiefs jerseys.
We're like a week away
from them going door to door,
scribbling...
...in the memo line
of everyone's stimulus check.
It has been a surreal
and heartbreaking year
of pain, suffering, and misery
for millions of people
and, while we're
at a crossroads, right now,
with a mix of caution
and competent governance,
we can get to the end
of this soon,
but we can't forget
the lessons of the past.
One of our two
major political coalitions
became unmoored from reality,
dismissed an urgent
public health threat,
and presided over needless
suffering and death,
all while trying
to overthrow democracy
and, now,
exactly one year later,
the other coalition,
whatever its faults,
has delivered urgent relief
to the poor
and working-class Americans
who need and deserve it.
Relief that's massively popular
with a majority of Americans
of all political persuasions.
So, Republicans,
most voters may not like you,
but, hey, at least maybe...
-"The stripper
really likes you."
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wear a mask.
Get vaccinated.
We love you.